wer bei shampoo
jede seite
er weiß schon heute wogen sind immer
wieder dass neu beginnt
servus wir sind hier in der stadthalle
reutlingen wir spielen heute mit großem
orchester
gemischtes publikum alte leute und junge
leute das wird wieder eine
herausforderung für uns 730 gramm gleich
generale und dann weiter am zaun
wunderschön
also das ist die württembergische
philharmonie reutlingen muss mal kurz im
hier werden wir auf und ab springen da
vorne darauf die crowd
die kleider von guten soundtrack gemacht
jetzt hört sich auf der bühne ist das
allerwichtigste bei dieser band
ich glaube da geht es richtig ab
die leute werden richtig spaß
es macht total spaß mit 1 56 zu
musizieren und verschiedene
musikrichtungen zusammenzubringen uns
als klassiker
die als hip-hopper man bildet ein world
team
ich möchte drei spielen gleich das wären
wir sogar schon ein paar mal gemacht und
haben wir mal was auch immer schön in
anzug gespielt und sind im laufe der
zeit darauf gekommen dass es einfach
authentisch ist wenn wir uns so anziehen
wir uns wohl fühlen
ernst gekommen
endspurt
ich versuchte mich
um zu leben
liedern zu pflegen
übersehen und will es nicht
er startet
das erste mal wirklich dass
dann steht um mir zu definieren zu
lassen und nicht